c'est grâce à des petits paradis comme
celui ci et la georgie et adoré
découverte du monde marin
[Musique]
un vignoble afin montagne une
gastronomie des cubes colorés du caucase
la paix et le spi qualité familier
[Musique]
maria et ses parents ont transformé la
maison ancestrale petite auberge pour
partager son histoire ses traditions et
prendre part à la manne qui devenu le
tourisme au fil des ans les chambres
qu'on vide mais juste avant la pandémie
80% la clientèle venait de l'étranger
américain sous les éclats la réouverture
de la frontière prévue sous peu
l'anglais c'est le dilemme d'à peu près
tous les pays dont l'économie repose sur
le tourisme
la famille attend donc impatiemment
verdict du gouvernement qui décidera qui
rentrait en géorgie et à quelqu'un
we are quite picchi select la ministre
de l'économie de la georgie nous a
ouvert les portes de son bureau où elle
mène nouveau genre de diplômes est ce
corridor
pire quand c'est fini
la géorgie a choisi la prudence et
négocié des ententes avec une poignée de
pays seulement vi nations qui comme elle
figure sur la liste des destinations les
plus sûrs grâce à leur gestion
exemplaire de la pandémie
pour le moment des négociations sont en
cours avec les pays baltes la grèce
israël l'allemagne l'autriche
ils portent tous bien l'idée de créer
des corridors verts ou des bulles
touristiques comme on les appelle pour
limiter la propagation du virus
[Musique]
à tbilissi la capitale le décompte et
lens car pour être un tel slogan les
hôtels seront soumis à des règles parmi
les plus sévères du monde
we had métiers ou des gains pour les
tests de dépistage de la cobi 30
obligatoire avant même de prendre
l'avion
et c'est une preuve d'assurance santé
pour le séjour un accueil plutôt froid
mais nécessaire un poste au gouvernement
a convenu que c'était la seule façon de
sauver une industrie qui représente le
tiers l'économie du pays pour des pays
émergents et nous ne sommes pas seuls
dit la présidente de l'association
touristique de georgie c'est l'occasion
de se vendre comme alternative à des
destinations classées comme la france
nikkei
mais quand rouvrir la porte aux
étrangers mais aussi des renoncer pour
le moment aux millions de russes et
américains qui posent leurs bagages
ici chaque année ah non c'est tout
simplement trop dangereux di maria est
limitée à des corridors sécuritaire est
selon elle la bonne décision
qui aurait cru calais huit mille ans
d'histoire et de culture
ce qu'il savait sur la pandémie qui
permet à la georgie d'un visage et son
futur
[Musique]